la télé ça gonflable tout à fait je
crois que c'est vraiment des métiers les
plus dangereux qu'on puisse faire pour
son intégrité pour son équilibre pour la
sagesse qu'on peut rechercher pour
soi-même
Michel
tu t'es déjà qu'on fait c'est jamais
quel effet
pas grand chose
parce que je me confesse à moi-même
tu favorable à l'euthanasie alors tout à
fait je souhaite vivement pour moi-même
je suis tout le temps malade je me dis
le jour où vraiment il le faudra sans
hésiter
pour les autres ça les regarde
tu n'es pas contre le suicide pas du
tout c'est même une porte de sortie très
honorable et je trouve que ça donne un
sentiment de liberté quand vraiment
quelque chose devient insoutenable il
faut pouvoir se dire il vaut mieux le
suicide que que le déshonneur pour
parler avec des grands mots
tu as souvent parlé du suicide comme une
arme contre la compromission oui oui je
crois que ne pas avoir peur de la mort
c'est-à-dire du suicide est une façon de
de résister à la peur à
l'humiliation à tout ce qu'on peut vous
proposer comme comme corruption aussi
inutile de demander si tu es favorable à
la peine de mort
et ben je vais te surprendre je suis
plutôt favorable à la peine de mort pour
une raison très simple c'est que la
prison me paraît beaucoup plus
effrayante que la mort s'ils ont j'avais
le choix pour moi-même je préférerais
qu'on me fiche une balle dans la tête
que de m'enfermer à vie dans une prison
tu crois en Dieu
non je crois dans le tout dans le cosmos
dans quelque chose qui rayonne mais Dieu
comme une personne qui surveillerait mes
actes et qui se pencheraient sur mon
sort alors là ça me fait un peu sourire
tu as dit de toi que tu étais un
athéistique ça veut dire quoi ça
c'est que je suis un peu panthéiste que
je crois que le
l'univers tout entier quelque chose qui
peut être considéré comme à la fois
exaltant et terrifiant c'est-à-dire qu'à
la fois le ciel et l'enfer mais il y a
pas que l'enfer il y a le ciel et
ça m'exalte
tu crois au diable
je commence à me poser la question parce
qu'en vieillissant je vois tellement ce
renouveler les mêmes horreurs que je me
dis qu'il y a une fatalité dans l'homme
et que ça pourrait s'appeler le diable
mais en fait c'est un mot de marionnette
c'est du guignol
tu regrette pas d'avoir perdu tout ce
temps à faire de la presse de la télé de
pas avoir été écrivain ah si ça je le
regrette certainement mais je veux dire
que là aussi on a un destin je pense que
c'est un regret idiot parce que j'étais
certainement fait pour faire ce métier
et que je l'ai fait longtemps à regret
en me disant mais tu perds ton temps
puis maintenant je me dis après tout je
continue très secrètement à faire mon
métier d'écrivain donc après tout
l'équilibre est rétabli
à 25 ans quand tu as publié la vie à un
certain chez Gallimard avec un certain
succès tu t'es posé la question ah mais
j'isoler pour écrire ah mais tout à fait
mais je n'arrêtais pas de le faire je
l'ai fait de ma vie j'ai fui en
permanence pour ça que ça m'arrangeait
bien de claquer la porte de fichu à la
porte c'était une occasion pour moi
d'aller écrire et il m'est arrivé de
passer des mois tout seul dans la
montagne pour écrire le résultat était
peut-être pas toujours à la hauteur de
l'effort que je faisais
la télé ça gonflable tout à fait je
crois que c'est vraiment des métiers les
plus dangereux qu'on puisse faire pour
son intégrité pour son équilibre pour la
sagesse qu'on peut rechercher pour
soi-même
ça te manque pas du tout pas du tout je
crois que
je crois vraiment que c'est une sorte de
drogue et qui veut savoir s'en passer et
indispensable
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu